جميع المخابز في محافظه غزه وشمالها توقفت
عن العمل بحسب وزاره الداخليه في غزه
والسبب عدم توفر الوقود والدقيق اما السبب
الرئيسي فهو الحصار الاسرائيلي والقصف
المتواصل على القطاع وتدمير عدد من
المخابز اما المتحدثه باسم برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي فتقول كنا نتعامل مع 23 مخبزا في
غزه لكن لا يوجد الان سوى مخبز واحد وكانت
الامم المتحده قالت ان تسعه مخابز تعمل
بالتعاون معها تزود السكان بالخبز وحذرت
من ان العديد منها قد يغلق في غضون ايام
بسبب نقص الوقود والمياه خطر المجاعه
يفاقم قطع قوات الاحتلال لامدادات المياه
وقصف محطاتها اذ لم يتبقى سوى محطه واحده
لتحليه المياه تعمل بالحد الادنى وهو ما
يهدد بالجفاف والامراض المنقوله كما حذرت
الاونروا من ان الناس قد يموتون بدون ماء
اذ تقدر منظمه الصحه العالميه الحد الادنى
من الاحتياجات اليوميه من المياه بنحو 100
لتر للشخص الواحد بما يشمل الشرب والغسيل
والطهي والاستحمام وقد كان متوسط استهلاك
المياه في غزه قبل الحرب نحو 844 لترا لكل
شخص 27 لترا منها فقط صالحه للاستخدام
البشري حاليا تقدر منظمه الصحه العالميه
متوسط استهلاك المياه في غزه بنحو ثلاثه
لترات فقط للشخص الواحد ما يفاقم خطر
المجاعه كذلك ان قطاع غزه بلا كهرباء عقب
اغلاق محطه توليد الكهرباء الوحيده وايقاف
قوات الاحتلال للامدادات ويقدر ان نحو 80%
من المباني والمنشات بدون كهرباء باستثناء
تلك التي تحتوي على مولدات كالمستشفيات
وملاجئ الامم المتحده وتظهر صور الاقمار
الصناعيه فقدان غزه للاضواء ليلا بنسبه
90% تقريبا في بعض المناطق اما معظم
النقاط المضيئه فهي المستشفيات قبل الحرب
كان نحو 80% من سكان غزه بحاجه الى
المساعدات وكانت تدخل القطاع 500 شاحنه
يوميا لكن منذ بدء الحرب الاسرائيليه لم
يدخل القطاع سوى
شاحنه